- "Modern Family" ended last year
after 11 seasons and 22 Emmys.
That's amazing!
(audience clapping)
Do y'all, and I imagine after that
many seasons of being around each other
especially growing up around them,
do y'all keep in touch?
- We do, we have a group chat.
I actually just, I FaceTimed
Ed and we, Ed O'Neill,
and we FaceTimed for like an hour,
at least an hour around my birthday
and it was just so sweet.
He's so funny everyone.
We like to keep in touch.
I'm probably the most
annoying person on it
'cause I'm, I have a confession.
I'm a Multi texter.
- Oh, me too.
Yeah, ear me on the voice coach text.
Yep.
We have a text game, the voice coaches.
It doesn't matter what season it is.
Whatever coaches are involved.
I'm the one that's like blue, blue, blue
and then there's like one
gray, blue, blue, blue.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just like my thoughts.
I type as I think so.
- Me too.
- I'm so sorry for that,
it bugs me.
I just, I just don't have a filter.
- Yeah, no me, me neither.
I know, well somebody
has got, gotta be us.
Let's might as well be us.